and you may be aware we've been talking
about comic-con all week I'm actually
there right now the real Chris Hardwick
anyhow this is an Android clone hosting
a show the only difference between us is
that I'll go in to kill all humans mode
if anyone says my secret trigger word
and also I'm smooth like a Ken doll
gentlemen gentlemen area don't listen to
him my penis is wider but tonight we're
going to talk about some of the many
other gatherings where you can let your
freak flag fly
for example the world's largest furry
convention took place in Pittsburgh
earlier this month this particular
convention of people who dresses cartoon
animals for reasons that may or may not
be darkly sexual is unusual only because
normally they stay inside some stuffy
hotel but now these horny hybrids parade
through the streets as seen in this clip
from the KDKA Action News 2 Benesch Dez
there's more than just fun and frolic
under all that fur tedious craftsmanship
transforms everyday humans into mythical
beasts with anthropomorphic features and
sorry enjoying as oh look it's less
unsettling than I thought it would be
[Applause]
and I thought it would be I'm here in
fact appeal in the dolphin man performed
cunnilingus on the sheep later that poor
lady she didn't do anything wrong
why don't I gotta be taking about
everything okay wait I guess it's not
that I'm settling you've ever been to a
parade with floats in costumes and this
would not be that on for you in any way
but comedians what's something else you
would overhear from a bystander at this
pet procession and it's about what
they're hiding on the inside yes very
good point Dave
I brought my kid here to teach them
about the birds and the bees and all the
other animals that are circle jerking on
that dog Emily Heller
oh I'm actually a dog in a human costume
yes very good boy
very good I guess they go to a slicky
convention on the other side of the
fence they're all dogs and humans all
dozen discussing so business how they
say us we are not just for sex I mean
we like to take a bowl
[Laughter]